among the features available
in deep chain we integrated a molecular
dynamics simulation tool
it allows users to simulate and
visualize
the molecular dynamics of protein
complexes
these full-scale gpu-powered simulations
compute the physical movements
of the molecules through time in the
context of protein complexes
the analysis of molecular dynamic
evolution can be informative
of their stability the md simulations
can be found in the upper right tab of
the workspace
new design can be created by either
uploading a local pdb file
or downloading one from the rcsb pdb
database
using a four letter code once your
design has been created
you can select it from the existing
designs panel
as the simulations for the molecular
dynamics can take several hours
we're going to load a design for which
the simulations have already been
computed
for the sake of the demo here we're
going to select a bone morphogenesis
protein complex we enter the md
simulations tab
running a simulation from our design's
native structure can be performed by
clicking this button
the number of minimization and
simulation steps
can be adjusted in the pop-up window
beforehand
in our case we can see here that a
molecular dynamic simulation for our
native protein complex has already
been launched and was completed
successfully the results of the
molecular dynamics simulation can now be
explored
the first panel is dedicated to the
parameters of the protein movements
visualization
by adjusting the two available sliders
the simulation can be viewed either
frame by frame
or played as a video with the speed of
your choice
below them you'll find a graph
displaying the evolution of the global
complex energy with time
thank you for watching and enjoy deep
chain